Stupid little fucking tube of paper that sucks in danger,
dangerous chemicals,
and you're telling me that I should be worried about the end of the world you're
in.
The world is happening right now.
I'm watching it.
You're inhaling,
you're,
you're addicted to a fucking little stick.
So true.
Yeah.
You're under the world's already here.
Stupid I,
the world is not necessarily predetermined.
We who knows how this is all going to turn out.
That's part of the fun of the movie.
That's part of the fun of the theatrical production.
That is your life.
It's true.
If we knew everything that was going to take place,
it would be so boring.
If you knew that you were now in heaven and you get to bang some chick anytime
you want for the rest of your life and you get to eat all the food you want it
for the rest of life,
you think that it would be awesome,
but it's not without risks,
not without failure.
You need all those things.
Human being,
you need to reach struggle.
You need struggle.
It's part of,
we are some sort of a monkey that creates things.
And if we don't create things,
whether you create ideas,
whether you create relationships,
whether you create houses,
whether you create jokes,
wherever the fuck you put forth,
that's what makes human beings happy.
If you're just living in the clouds banging chicks and eat and food,
you would fucking live in hell.
You don't think you would,
but eventually you would be in hell.
You'd be in some weird situation where a giant part of what it is to be a human
is removed from the equation.
Yeah.
And it just goes back to what we talked about with Welfare.
You,
you,
you've got to work to get something.
You can't just get it.
There has to be a struggle or you don't evolve.
And as soon as you introduce the option of no struggle,
you introduced the option of,
you know,
and people think that the struggle is over financially.
It's one of the reasons why when people are successful,
a lot of people go,
oh man,
he sold out.
Um,
you know,
he's not hip anymore.
The,
the struggle is never financial.
The stroke did.
The best part about overcoming the financial struggle is now the struggle gets
to be about thoughts and ideas.
Now the struggle gets to be about creating shit and now the struggle gets to be
about getting the center of what the fuck this is getting to the center of what
is this life?
And you can guess what you can think about.
What is this life a whole lot more when you're a comedian that gets to wake up
at one in the afternoon and it doesn't necessarily have to do anything all day,
and you can sit in front of your computer computer drinking coconut juice and
smoking pot and reading online.
You can think things through in a manner that the average person just never get
a chance to do.
And you ever have that opportunity to get paid for it too.
That's what kind of standup is putting it into a funny light,
but kind of like surprising people with where you're taking your idea.
Yeah,
that's what I mean.
it's,
it's putting forth something you have.
It's,
and it's gotta be hard,
man.
I write shit sometimes and I'm a fucking gold and man this bit sucks.
There's something missing in this bit.
Like I know it's Dan but I don't know it's there.
And then there's this thing that I have just figured out how to do like over the
last couple of years where I used to have a theme,
like I would say,
okay,
today I'm going to write about Viagra,
we're going to sit down and going to write some shit about Viagra.
And then I would start about that and maybe it would go in a different
direction,
but not too far off path.
Now I just sit down and I open up a page and I just let it go.
I just get high as fuck and I let it all go,
whatever crazy thought I have.
And then in the morning I get up sober and then I look at what I wrote and I go,
what the fuck am I talking about?
Like some I write shit sometimes when I'm high and I go back and read it and I'm
like,
this doesn't even seem like it's me writing this.
Like,
who the fuck wrote this?
It makes sense sometimes.
Yeah,
sometimes.
Yeah.
Sometimes it doesn't though,
but that's part of,
that's part of the whole zone that you get into when you're creating something
and you can't be afraid of looking silly for so many years where you never,
you never even smoked a joint.
Do anything.
Yeah.
What was your,
what was your turn,
what did Stan hope gets you?
No,
no.
Eddie Bravo.
Eddie Bravo for sure.
100%.
He,
uh,
he was a really good at Jujitsu and uh,
we were hanging out together just because we took classes together and he gave
me some private lessons and tied me up and it not,
we,
uh,
I was training with this guy.
Other guy was taking private lessons with his black belt.
It's a very nice guy.
He had good intentions,
but I could roll with him,
but I knew his game,
you know,
and you get to a certain point where you could roll the guy like,
I could tap them out and it very rare,
but occasionally I can get them with something.
And part of it was him like being Roland Nice with me and real easy with me and
let me get things.
But also I knew his game.
Right?
But when you start rolling with someone else,
you realize,
oh,
you got to roll with a bunch of different people.
You can't just roll with one person because Eddie Bravo just went right through
me.
He just destroyed me.
Part of it was because he was way better than me and really,
uh,
an amazing Jujitsu guy.
Like he's a genius,
a Jujitsu genius,
a true genius,
every sense of the word.
But it was also because I sucked.
I thought it was good cause I knew how to wrestle with one guy.
I knew his weaknesses.
I was physically a little faster than him and I can do things.
But then I started rolling with other people.
I was getting tapped all the time.
I was like,
oh,
okay.
I got a joint class.
Right?
So anyway,
Eddie said,
you know,
I'd be happy to give you some private lessons.
I said,
oh awesome.
So we went out,
we got some lunch,
get some private lessons,
and we started talking about creativity and life and music and stuff.
Cause he's a musician and he said that he writes his best stuff and he's stoned.
And I was like,
that doesn't even make sense.
Like you're high and you're,
I'm thinking when you're high.
I was like,
Oh,
you dope.
You know,
you'd lose her.
like the,
the,
the moments in my life where I had been drunk,
I was embarrassed about those moments.
I never like look back at a time I was struggling.
I can now.
Right.
You know,
now,
you know,
we'll like,
ah,
there were fucking hammered and we're talking shit at the bar and it's fun.
That to me,
um,
you know,
I'm,
I'm in control of my shit now.
Right.
So what if me and Brian and Joey Diaz do shots at the,
the,
in the green room and the Portland,
uh,
you know,
a helium.
I don't feel bad about that.
I feel like we had a good time.
It was crazy.
The next day I had a headache.
You know what I mean?
But back then I was embarrassed about anything that I did that wasn't positive.
And anything that I did that cut might make me a loser.
Anything that I did that my keeping.
Yeah.
So he,
uh,
he was so adamant about how we'd made him like a really creative,
and I was like,
all right,
let's do this.
Come on,
pull over.
So,
uh,
we,
we smoked pot and then we had some ice cream and uh,
and it was amazing.
It was the greatest ice cream I've ever had in my life.
And I couldn't believe that marijuana made this cream so fucking good.
I had an ice cream Sundae with hot fudge and it was the most incredible.
I,
the sensation of eating the food was so heightened.
I felt like a fool.
I felt like I can't believe that all my,
and that started.
That was,
yes,
that was it.
You know,
it was like I was talking to him and he's this fascinating guy.
I mean,
Eddie is a very fascinating guy.
He's very,
he's a free thinker.
He had a really hard childhood man.
My childhood was not,
my childhood was not,
not terrible.
It wasn't that it wasn't ideal.
I have a lot of shit happened to me.
I think a lot of us did,
all of us here did,
but his was horrific and because of that he developed disability to just fuck
you.
Like push people away,
like focus on his goals and see things in a different way.
You know,
he had,
he had this ability to like,
he's got this ability to look at life and break things down and a lot of times
when we have conversations he comes at it from a completely different angle than
I do,
you know?
And I like that about you too.
You will often do that too.
And Duncan,
we'll do that all the time.
I love when people,
like when I have a friend that's a close friend that's very smart,
that will take things in a different way and I don't necessarily always agree
with them,
but it's a,
it's a fascinating thing.
It's almost like you,
if you,
if you value their opinion and if you talk to them about things like you have
one more,
you out there interpreting,
interpreting the world from another possible angle.
It's so important.
It's,
yeah.
And so I met him and right away I knew,
I'm like,
this guy is smart as fuck.
He's,
he's a Weirdo.
He's figured out some shit about your Jitsu and if you can get that good at
Jujitsu and like you can get that at it.
A lot of fencing.
You're a bad motherfucker.
And he's a little guy.
I'll get,
he's not strong at all.
So he got really good at Jujitsu all based on technique and leverage and he does
everything the right way.
So you,
you,
you learn from a guy like that.
So I,
I met him and I was like,
okay.
So obviously there's some good to this week.
You can't think that it's all bad.
Who,
who,
who do you think is the best?
Uh,
I couldn't believe that my whole life.
I thought it was for losers.
This is,
imagine you sitting there the first couple of times he's like,
I can feel it in my hands.
Heady.
Oh yeah.
It was totally like,
I'm like,
I'm a complete rookie shit.
I remember Joey Diaz.
I said something to Joey Diaz once.
He goes,
look at this fucking rookie.
Get the fuck Outta here.
I forget what I said to him.
What are some rancher ideas?
Some crazy,
some crazy rookie uh,
pod experience.
I was timid to me.
I was calling him like,
it was the most profound thing that I ever heard.
He goes,
get the fuck out of here with that rookie shit.
He talking to me without getting high mother fucker.
That's what's going on.
Joey Diaz will break things down.
I'm can't get not cock sucker.
That's just unbelievable.
If you ain't,
I buy two in the afternoon.
Go Fuck Yourself.
There's actually a a t shirt that we put out on hire dash [inaudible] dot com
sold out instantly.
We got new ones coming out,
folks.
I swear to God,
I got a lot more this time.
I'm buying as many as you can and proceed to go to the Joey Diaz we'd fund.
So all the t shirt money is right now.
He's got a fat check come to them.
You'll keep him in.
We'd for weeks.
So this,
that tee shirt should pay for all of Joey's weed for the rest of his life.
That's my goal.
If we keep,
you know,
if he makes enough money off this tee shirt every month just to cover off his
weed expenses,
plus a few,
a few nice dinners here and there.
I think it's this fucking winner of a shirt,
man.
I can't wait to wear it.
I don't even have one.
We don't even have one.
It says if it's based on something you said once in the podcast,
and by the way,
he says all the time,
it wasn't just that moment.
He says it all the time now.
He says it all the time.
He says,
if you ain't hot,
he'll go.
He'll call me up sometimes and I'll answer the phone.
We'll just go,
if you ain't I buy two in the afternoon,
go fuck yourself dog.
I am playing dog.
I ain't playing right now.
I got the banana bread from the Russians.
Fuck that.
Banana bread.
Banana bread is the bomb.
Diggity son.
Yeah.
Where does this banana bread is to psychedelic?
Right.
I fucking gave me a heart attack.
I was blown away by your share ideas,
impersonations and cock sucker.
I can only do a couple of impressions,
but I can do them.
Geez,
that's not that good.
If he was in the room,
I could really do them.
I can.
I can imitate people.
It's okay.
Did you,
were you on Mad TV during with Matt?
Her was on,
no.
Oh,
okay.
There's this,
that guy we had on this show.
If you ever seen Ikea Heights.
No.
What does that,
it's a,
these guys that now,
this Guy Matt Rung who was also on Mad TV.
We had them on you,
Tommy stickers and Christina show.
Uh,
but he was talking about how he was on this thing that you can find on the
Internet.
It's fucking hilarious.
Where these,
this comedy trip goes into an Ikea.
They do like a CSI type show in the middle of Ikea,
like without Ikea knowing like they have employees or that are a part of the
production that will like take like the employees of Ikea and like get them
distracted and then they'll have like full on like gun guns and cops,
shootouts,
you know like in the middle of like a bedroom in Ikea and they,
so they use Ikea as a stage for CSI.
It's fucking hilarious.
It's one of the funniest things.
They had to stop doing it because they just were getting kicked out every
episode,
like intercompany kicks away.
Oh this is really cool that
these guys are actually doing a TV show in a status Ikea yet.
And instead it's like really funny and,
and it's all him prompts using,
yes,
it's Ikea Heights dotcom and they're in a kitchen now and then they're in the
basement.
That's fine as ideas where you go,
why the fuck didn't I think of that?
I know.
And I guess supposedly like they can't do it anymore because they've just gotten
too much trouble.
He keep doing it changes a malt.
Walmart.
I'd say the last one they did kia heights,
Ikea Heights.
Last one they did,
they had like a Zombie attack or something like that,
so they just had some bs.
But I was thinking instead of doing it again and getting in trouble,
Ikea act like they move like,
cause like you know how like in TV shows they moved to different cities.
So like Kmart,
Kmart Boulevard or something like that.
And that'd be the whole show.
But they probably,
we will,
we probably don't even need to give them that idea.
They thought of that idea.
Must must've thought they couldn't have said yes,
it's over.
They're kicking us out now.
They're going to go somewhere else.
[inaudible] dot com or something.
Ikea heights.com and the podcast we had mad on was a your mom's house number 14
squad
on iTunes.
Hilarious.
Dude,
that's a great idea.
Every now and then,
you know,
one of those ideas comes along,
we'd like,
wow.
Yeah.
That's one of,
that's a,
that's stellar.
It is.
That's what I love about,
you know,
I love,
I love being in the comedy community is such an interesting community,
you know?
I mean,
it feels weird to even say that you're a part of it.
We're all,
we all have this weird sort of,
I dunno,
you don't,
you have like a weird sort of like a humility about the business and,
you know,
it's,
it's a,
it's a weird thing to even say like,
yeah,
you know,
I'm a problem freshen up comedian.
That's what I do.
It seems like it all seems like I won't enter that discussion.
It's,
it seems,
it seems odd and weird.
Somebody said to me,
you know,
you're professionally funny and my buddy Jimmy Burke said,
you are professionally,
so I'll show you is you are a pro.
And I was like,
oh boy,
that's a,
it's a wide,
so it's a weird thing.
It's,
it goes contrary to the idea of being,
or what makes you funny in the first place.
But,
um,
but being a part of the community,
like you having people like you as a friend and having people like,
you know,
uh,
nick Swardson come over and Corolla come over and all these people that I'm
like,
wow,
nick Swardson's hanging out here.
Yeah.
And Adam Carolla's really sitting there and you're really sitting there.
It's the fucking greatest thing ever.
The great,
the greatest community to be a part of people who make you laugh.
It's true.
It's like a part of this fraternity or something.
I always feel like,
you know,
boy,
when you've done the road and when you've been on stage and you know,
so different audiences are so different.
You don't know how they're gonna respond.
You've got,
you've gone through something and we were at the backstage of the UFC and it was
a big UFC event and it fucking place was packed.
But Jim Norton and Bobby Kelly showed up and I saw Jim Norton and Bobby Kelly
and I shot towards them like a slingshot.
Like I made a beeline to them because I knew that's where the fun talk was going
to be fun.
You know,
Jimi fucking doors there and Bobby Kelly and Kelly's,
I've known Bobby Kelly since we were like 21 kills me.
Bobby was with Allen,
the monkeys and Dane Cook and that they were an Improv troupe and I was the
headliner and they would open for me and we did a bunch of those,
uh,
cuckoos a addict already comedy huts.
So we worked together a bunch of times when those guys were just coming up.
I was like a couple of years ahead of them,
but they were,
they were close.
I've been,
yeah,
I hung out with Bobby Kelly like back in the day,
like,
so I've known him since you ain't even know him bobbing and Dan for a long
shore.
I've known Dan forever.
I knew Dan before he ever did stand up on his own.
He did it in a troop.
He did it in the Allen,
the monkeys.
What they would do is they would do sketches and uh,
you know,
they were taking chances.
It was creative stuff.
And then they would each do stand up.
They would each do like five minutes of standup and then I would go on stage
after them.
And it was like,
it was kind of like,
oh,
I wouldn't say like they,
they,
they were opening,
but it was so much different than an opening act.
They had a lot of shit going on.
Like they did.
It was interesting to you guys,
man.
Yeah.
So,
and you know,
so I've known Bobby since,
like I said,
I was like 24,
you know,
and he was probably a couple of years younger than me,
like maybe 21 crazy.
I see them and man,
it's what we were saying.
It's like these are,
these are like,
these are like soldiers.
They're like feller fellow,
a fellow travelers in this weird world of show business.
I'd have a lot of pride in it.
I do too.
I was,
I did a New Year's eve show and I was in Ontario at the Improv and it was just
packed.
And,
and,
um,
I was,
we were about to count off
the new year and I,
I remember just stopping and I had the mic in my hand and I went,
I really meant this too.
I said,
you know,
I feel like a successful person.
Like I can't believe I get to do this for a living.
And I said,
if I died tomorrow,
I got,
I can't complain comparatively to what,
how most people have to live their lives,
their treasury.
And I get paid to make people laugh for two hours a night and I,
and I get to do whatever I want when I want.
It's like the lottery.
It's not easy,
you know,
inventing yourself.
There's a lot of lot of weird shit that goes on in the creating of material and
the going up there and fucking around with it.
And two,
you know,
and it never gets easy in a way.
Like it really doesn't,
that's why it's so satisfying when it comes out.
I just did it.
Just like we were talking about with Welfare and the lottery and all that shit
with you have to have,
the only thing that's different to me is relationships.
Relationships.
I want no work.
Yeah,
I agree.
I want friendliness and love.
I don't want to work.
That's a good point.
I don't have to work for that.
I want to fight all the time.
Like there's people that think that you have to fight and I think that's,
that's a crock of shit.
You just got to find something like that.
But he a nice person and find someone that doesn't want to fight.
Comedy.
Comedy is one of the things,
like I just did a,
a benefit with Garry Shandling and Kevin Nealon and uh,
um,
uh,
Brad Garrett who killed me and Ray Romano.
What'd you guys do this at?
The Wilshire theaters for children with AIDS.
And uh,
it was this last weekend and we all went up and did it.
We all eat.
Did I did a half hour.
But you know,
the rest of the guys did like 20 minutes and it was,
we just had so much fun.
It was so fun.
And it was,
it was,
everybody was a hilarious,
and Brad Garrett fucking kill me.
He's waiting for him in Long Island,
east side Comedy Club in 1991 killin Doris Roberts.
And she was in the audience just like,
well,
how old are you?
She was 91 when she did the shelf or credit going in,
how are you drinking?
Are you drunk sweetie?
Yet?
You know,
and he was killing everybody.
This black woman was in the,
and the thing that she was really old,
it goes,
look at her from the civil war.
I must be so different now for you,
isn't it?
I mean,
killing him,
he was amazing.
Or the civil rights and he just saw a reference,
but he was fucking killing the room.
And then we were all backstage and I,
and I'm letting you know,
Garry Shandling and,
and all these guys are in some ways,
you know,
big,
they've done a lot of stuff in comedy for 2030 years and they were all talking
about how did they just all have so much reverence for comedy?
And it's still not easy.
No matter what and it's still a challenge and you're still,
you better respect that bitch.
Better respect,
better respect that bitch.
Cause if you don't,
you'll be up on stage realizing you didn't respect it and eating it and it was a
bunch of people paid to see you don't so true.
That motivates the fuck out of me.
Ever gets old.
You're gonna be on stage for an hour,
my friend bring the money.
You said that one time I did.
I remember long time ago,
this was fucking 13 years ago,
I did Friday nights or something that you were emceeing and I got up and I did
this weird story and you were like,
and you were like really comment and he said,
you know,
you'd do the most usual shit.
He goes,
but you could ever do that shit on the road.
In some cities they'd be like,
fucking Purdue gotta bring the money.
If you're going to do an hour,
you've got to bring the money.
Guess what?
You gotta be fucking funny for an hour because people lose their attention span.
That room gets quiet quick.
Even if you're a famous Michael Richards out on the floor,
so people get an Andrew,
they're on your side for five minutes.
You got five,
maybe seven,
maybe if you're Brad Pitt and then [inaudible] and it just fucking tumbleweeds
turns the other way.
I hear a dog bark in the distance and they fucking hate you.
It turns the other way.
Charlie Sheen it off stays.
What a surprise.
Monetizing his madness.
As at one of my,
one of my friends says,
that is a good way of putting it.
Jeremy Piven said that he goes,
we sanitize it was a smart guy.
Yup.
That is what it is sort of.
I mean,
it's also,
you know,
he's trying to figure out some way to get the public on his side because he's
got some giant lawsuit coming up.
Crazy.
You think?
I mean,
winning,
winning.
He's,
he's uh,
with a goddess.
That's a guy.
Fuck.
Cocaine and who just hasn't been living in the real gain confidence.
That's 25 years of fame.
By the way,
in Hollywood,
you're an alien and Graham rocks and winning and Warner Brothers still has his a
speak posts.
Rocks.
Yeah.
Brian thinks it's all,
Brian thinks it's all a scam to make two and a half men the biggest show ever
next season when he comes back and his triumphant return,
he thinks it's all orchestrated.
The horrors banner of their show.
Corechange choking,
choking,
porn stars almost threatening to stab his wife winning if you got,
has he got a lawsuit coming?
Yeah,
he does.
Apparently according to Hollywood insiders.
Oh,
from,
from cvs.
Yes.
Apparently it Connie dog,
Hollywood insiders.
He actually has a very good point because the guy didn't show up for work late.
It wasn't like he was missing set shoots and costing them money.
He was always fucked up.
They knew it was fucked up from a long time ago.
They hired him under the premise that he was his party animal and guess what?
That's what he fucking plays on the show.
He plays a watered down version of the real life job chain.
Exactly.
It sounds like a big dick contest.
That's what it sounds like.
It sounds like him and that guy who was the executive producer there waving the
dicks around and the executive producer doesn't want this junky back on his set
and he wants to move on,
but he's going to ruin a lot of fucking people's jobs.
Stay was that he was able to,
he could strangle a girl everything else.
And then he made fun of Chuck Lorre on that radio show and that's when he got
fired.
Well that Chuck Lorre guy we talked about on the show before about all the shows
that he's produced.
He produced grace under fire.
He proves Roseanne.
He produced Sibbel.
He had to deal with con after comment after comment and he developed the ability
to put his fucking foot down.
You know?
And that's why he's so successful.
He's fucking good at what he does.
I guys got a gang of TV shows and listen man,
the bottom line is Charlie Sheen was probably very creatively unfulfilled.
You know,
and it's not to say the two and a half men wasn't a good show,
cause one,
honestly,
I never watched it.
I've never seen a single episode.
Not Bad.
So I don't know.
I watched like maybe one scene once.
I'm happy for Jon Cryer isn't the nicest fucking human being.
I met him a long time ago.
We did a college together and um,
stand up.
I don't think he did.
I'm pretty sure it was him.
It was,
he's about to,
cause he was in a movie before then.
I couldn't believe that.
I saw,
there was one of the first guys that I ever saw that had been in a movie.
I did a standup at this college.
Then he did something else.
It was like bigger than the same college.
I'm pretty in pink.
It was something,
yeah,
somewhere on those.
I'm pretty sure it was Jon cryer long,
long,
long time ago.
But the point is that,
you know,
he would probably mean the guy was in fucking platoon and Wall Street.
He was in two huge Oliver Stone's smash movies.
I mean,
and they were brilliant performances.
So when he's playing this silly guy and this silly show year after year making
mad,
mad loot,
the money piles up.
But then the ability to break away from the mundane becomes more and more
extreme.
It's just like the Catholic girl that wants to suck a dick and he's,
he's not being challenged as a grown man.
You didn't give yourself a fucking problem.
You're going to find a way to challenge yourself.
You're going to create a problem for yourself.
That shit happens all the time.
You get somebody to get to exactly what they want and they're a little too young
to handle it or they get exactly what they want.
They have no where else that they don't have the imagination and figure out
where else they can grow.
They get in the fucking trouble.
Too much money,
no imagination,
and you didn't earn it.
You're,
you're fucking,
even if you did or do respect the Charlie Sheen is trying to do is apparently
it's trying to evolve his show,
so he's bringing comics and Russell Peters is going to come on.
He's going to tell us about it because Russell's been,
I was in it for him.
He's great.
Someone please on Twitter verify Russell Peters,
the Real Russell p.
That's him.
So he can't get verified.
Wait,
he's having guests on the show are comics opening form comics.
What they do is the comics,
we'll interview him and there's video of him interviewing Russell Peters where,
or Russell Peters rather interviewing Charlie Sheen were Charlie sheen talks
about accidentally leaving his gun out and Kelly Preston was living with him and
she dropped the gun and shot her.
It shot the toilet and it ricocheted and hit her.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
She got hurt.
How does that happen?
That's,
you know,
Tracy Junkie Shit on a gun though.
I don't think that usually goes off.
Yeah,
it very well could have been.
Charlie just has good writers for the show.
He,
they've probably learned from the mistakes of the past that they actually have
to make this thing interesting because,
well that's what they're doing now.
But I mean the story's a true story,
but apparently who knows how much of it's true.
But Russell Peters was interviewing him.
That's how it didn't.
Then Russel says a bunch of Lou really funny lines in between it and just fucks
around with it.
And so now that sort of become sort of a show,
you know,
but I think they need to incorporate other things like they need to incorporate
music and some other shit.
I think I should just,
and I,
I haven't thought about Charlie Sheen and like three weeks.
Yeah,
but that's you.
That's you.
That's guy.
He's got everybody's [inaudible].
He's got it.
He's got something there.
If there's some sort of an interest moves to the country,
he starts dragging together a show.
That's what I'm saying.
I mean it's kind of fascinating.
Who knows?
I mean,
look,
the guy that whoever the fuck the guy is inside of him,
that was the guy that was in Wall Street or was the guy that was in platoon.
That guy is a bad motherfucker.
And if you could find who that guy is,
you know,
people lose their way and regain it.
It happens.
You know?
And it might be through this humility that he gets out of getting fired from his
fucking job and bested in this Dick Contest.
What do these kind of like a hundred million bucks or something.
So I don't know.
A lot of it might be in real estate.
A lot of it's,
you know,
a lot of,
a lot of times too,
when he was making more money than any human being had ever made on a sitcom,
he was making $2 million a fucking,
he's definitely got mine.
He's got some cash.
If he doesn't,
he's crate almost bought a hooker hotel.
There was a train goes by,
buy a house having that much money.
Yeah,
but that's some haterade the haterade.
I've never heard that before.
That's you.
The Internet Gurus never heard
Peter read his old dude.
I bet you if you look up Charlie sheen bankruptcy or Charlie sheen like,
like spent money,
you'll see that.
You're hoping right now.
Lucian Charlie was going broke and he went to Charlie's winning while you're
here doing your,
your,
what is the podcast?
Great.
Good stuff.
It's really,
really traveling well.
Doing well for you.
Big Time production here was that real foam over that microphone is show
running.
Joe Rogan.
He's very good at what he does.
A poop back and forth.
Good Luck Charlie.
Smoke weed and stay away from that cocaine,
those highs.
There's not,
there's not the good blow always.
Nobody ever did blow and went,
yeah,
I had all these problems.
They did a bunch of blow and then it fucking worked out in the history of the
world.
That's never been said.
Yeah,
that's not good.
That stuff's bad for you.
That's tough fries.
You're fucking Noggin.
Did you know Jimmy Hendrix died when he was 27 yeah.
It's not crazy to Janis Joplin.
Jim Morrison,
Morrison.
Cause I've ever,
I have any,
any sense of delusions of grandeur.
Just look at what Jimmy Hendrix compost and it was only 27 he said no Internet
Sandlin how about what that by the time our 24 I mean like cashmere and led
Zepplin want,
they were like 2120 that's ridiculous.
Ridiculous.
Like thinking about that.
They were writing fucking,
they were all educated.
They all read a shitload.
Jimmy page has a whole fucking library,
like a huge library of like I'm black magic and stuff.
Wow.
Jimmy page's is that scholar.
He,
they all those guys have read a lot.
I had this different station back then had this conversation the other day with
the lovely Brittany Palmer.
She's one of the ring girls with USC.
She's very nice.
She's dating my buddy.
That's Ronnie.
Yeah,
no,
she's,
she's dating my buddy Anthony now.
Powerful.
Your friend Anthony's getting some of that.
My buddies,
my buddy,
a writer and debated guy.
I just saw Brittany boom.
Anyway,
she's very nice person and she is fascinated by the 70s and the 60s and she's a
painter and she makes all these,
she's making all these different paintings and we were having this conversation
like I'm,
I'm,
I'm the same way when I listen to music,
nine times out of 10 when I'm driving in my car,
I'm listening to my iPod and it's usually like some,
some like 1970 Zeplin or it's some 1970s almond brothers or Leonard Skinner.
That shit to me just resonates.
You know,
when I listen to old music from like that era for whatever reason,
it just resonates and I'm trying to figure out what is it about that time?
What is it about the Jimi Hendrix,
what is it about Jim Morrison?
What it was.
It just because it was the first of that shit was it,
was it because it was the first,
this giant evolutionary breakthrough from the,
it's a combination of,
of a number of things.
One is that a lot of people back then thought their music was counted for
something.
In other words,
they thought that their music could actually change something.
And a lot of,
a lot of what happens with artists as cynicism's
at times have a certain cynical a of stamp on them.
And I think we live in a very cynical time,
the notion that nothing you do as an individual,
certainly as an artist could change anything at all.
That's very prevalent among artists.
So you don't have people who are doing standup,
for example,
to try to break a social norm or shatter a social norm.
You certainly don't have a lot of musicians saying,
my music is actually influenced the political atmosphere.
Remember it was after we had been through in the 70s we just spin through and
we're going through a terrible war in Vietnam and,
and you know how many people died?
54,000 men were killed.
That's a huge number where if you compare the wars in Afghanistan and Iraq,
it would say it was 4,000 death and a lot of injuries.
But I'm just saying that in a very short period of time,
we'd also been through a world we'd been through a number of that were in the
Cold War.
We'd been to a world war two and everybody had an act of memory of that.
That shit life really counted and mattered and people didn't live as long.
There was this,
there's this idea that you better hurry up and get through it and make your
fucking stamp while you still have an opportunity.
Because if you looked around and let's take 1974 and you looked around at the
world,
half the world was starving to death and,
and,
and for the them and half the world with living under communist dictatorships,
which was essentially slavery and half the world was a very dangerous place.
And that war,
and by the way,
there was an arms race called the nuclear arms race between the Soviet Union and
the United States.
And a lot of people really were like,
you know what,
we could all fucking just blow up.
The next war is going to be where the cockroaches and the rats are the only
things live in.
And there's always,
there was always that saying that if there is a third World War,
I think it was Einstein who said the,
the living,
the living will yeah.
And the living will envy the dead.
Right.
And that,
that a whole lot,
that idea,
cause you'll be start,
you'll be BCIT.
I don't know what's going to start the Third World War,
what weapons would be used,
but the fourth world be fought with sticks such a great quote.
But the point is that I think when you live in,
in times of great uncertainty and times of great hope and times of great
violence member in this country,
we'd come off a number of assassinations.
Martin Luther King,
Malcolm X,
John,
John Kennedy,
Joe Kennedy.
And it goes on and on.
I mean,
there was this notion that we were in a real battle and a real social battle,
um,
uh,
for our souls.
Man You had,
you had to governments sending young boys off to die in a war.
Most people hadn't even heard of that fucking part of the world.
And there was this idea that we're losing them.
We're we gotta,
we gotta get in the streets and say something and do something more importantly
if we do.
So Shit will change.
And people were getting to hose down and black people didn't have the vote until
1964 it was only 10 years old.
So when you think about how extreme things were,
and not only that,
but how uncertain and how it was the beginning of so many different ideas that
were competing that when,
when you get a very term but a society in turmoil usually.
And what's very positive about it is you want to cross current of ideas.
You want ideas bashing heads,
like fucking rams.
And,
and when you have that provided you keep the violence out of it,
but there's always gonna be a little violent.
But when you have that and people who,
who,
where they're fighting for their souls with an idea,
you're going to get something pretty fucking cool.
And you're,
and you're going to get certainly very volatile artistic expression and a lot of
that expression can very well be a miles Davis who was saying,
I'm a black man in America with,
you know,
and I still don't feel free or whatever it might be.
Or You could have,
um,
beeper.
I love Bieber is candy compared to think about it,
how much music counted back then?
Right?
Jazz was the only place that a lot of black people could really express
themselves,
honestly through a fucking horn.
So if your heart's broken,
you are the sing it or you shoot it through a horn because if you say otherwise,
you're going to get fucking hung or shot or arrested.
That's what it was to be black in the 1940s,
50s,
60s,
and even the 70s for a lot of them,
that's the bottom line.
It goes on and on.
So things were way more extreme.
And I think,
uh,
in today's world where everything's at the,
at the touch of a button where everybody has plenty to eat,
even if it's not healthy food.
Um,
and we feel safer and I don't think,
and I think we're cynical,
I don't believe that what we do and what we say can really change the world.
And back then you did
the thing is the numbers just to many the humans now,
no,
I mean there's still people that rage against the machine.
You don't kind of believe the same kind of shit.
I think we're going to face another,
uh,
we're going to face,
we're always going to face challenges as people and as a world and those
challenges may very well bring into question our own survival.
I don't think so for a long time.
I don't know.
No.
What's really changed in the world?
This thing run right now?
The Internet?
Yes.
Is this really the big change?
Very much the way we are right now.
Our parents were never like this.
These is,
we're never held and it gives more potential Joe for the notion that all of us
could get together and springboard into an idea and a major shift in colleges.
Something like this.
Like right now live,
there's 2000 people listening to us live and this is a tiny fraction of the
amount of people that will listen to us over the next few months.
You know,
it's going to be hundreds of thousands of people.
And these people,
when they start looking at the world,
the way you're talking about it,
the way you know,
stepping back and describing and say,
what is it?
What,
what is it to live with?
Passion.
What is,
what is important in this life?
what is the fun?
Where's the enjoyment?
Where's the,
where's the real true passion in this world?
Like what is it for you?
What is it for you?
And if you don't fucking find that your life's not going to be fun.
That's right.
And if don't get saddled down by debt,
don't get caught up in a lot of,
but also have backing on that.
Great Point is,
is you've got to find a way to keep yourself inspired.
Yeah.
Find ways.
I don't care what it is,
just truly be doing what you enjoy doing.
You'd be
stoked that those fires.
And one of the things about standup is the fear of bombing also gives you
another added incentive and motivation that I think some artists are without,
you know,
and they just produced books are just producing,
they're just wait for reviews.
But the fear of actual being in front of someone when they don't like you,
that's so much more intense than a shitty review.
It sure as cause you feel it right away,
man.
Yeah,
and it's not,
it was just,
I mean look,
just life is temporary and we all need to wrap our fucking heads around that.
If we all just step back,
this whole world is moving on momentum and that is our number one problem as a
race.
We're moving in the way that our ancestors had been moving and we don't,
no one ever just stops and goes,
whoa,
Whoa,
whoa.
Let's just settle down and talk this over.
Let's have a 30 day summit where we all the leaders of the world get together
and try to figure out how are we going to redesign the human race to make us all
function together?
How is there going to be a,
a,
a reasonable distribution of the natural resources of the earth so that one
country doesn't grow rich because they have the fucking missiles and the nuclear
bombs and that somehow or another,
it's distributed amongst everyone.
So we get to some sense of fairness and all work together to make sure that
people don't have too many fucking babies.
So we don't run out of food on this crazy rock,
like,
let's,
let's organize this thing and let's do it together.
The only way that's going to happen is the kids that are in college right now
who are listening to shit like this,
who are going online and researching the world and looking at things in a way
that we never had the,
uh,
the ability to,
and the access to information that we never had access to.
And they're,
they're getting a chance to see the world from a fresh eyes and fresh
perspective and realize that this is some weird thing.
We're all running in the same direction,
hoping that someone knows where we're going.
They're,
they're,
they're the future.
You,
you college motherfucker with the Bong right now.
This is for you.
Change the world.
Just figuring out a way to sift through all the information.
There'll be some in the system right now that will be sensitive to it and the
next wave will integrate.
And the next wave of people that are trying to be politicians would be like,
Gary Johnson will be like Ron Paul.
They'll realize there's freedom and love and,
and,
and telling the truth and really trying to do the right thing instead of being
some bitch to a corporation,
which is the most common,
most politicians are.
Most politicians are little hookers there.
Stick their ass up in the air and some corporation comes by and drop some money
and their pussy and that's what they are.
And that's what we have to realize.
We don't do.
You don't have to be like that.
What the fuck?
Who Cares?
The fear factor guy and the guy from a hangover to telling you how to run this
world by channeling,
take notes.
Take blame the weed for the last five minutes of this rant.
But it's true,
man.
You know,
and I hear it,
and not to say that this is why we're doing it,
but I,
I hear it all the time that this podcast changes the way people think.
And uh,
I think,
uh,
you know,
having a guy like you in my life has definitely changed the way I think.
And,
um,
I think,
you know,
all of us together,
we help each other and I'm very happy and very proud that we can dig and put out
this resource,
not just for entertainment,
this,
this podcast,
but also,
you know,
it gives you an opportunity to hear another point of view that you might not
come in contact with in your life.
I don't know too many people like you,
you know,
it's,
and it's hard to cultivate them.
I've done a real good job of trying to keep as many interesting people in my
life as possible because I think it's,
it's an enriching and I love you,
love conversations with you.
We have the craziest fucking conversations.
Yeah.
But we have had more on a regular basis since I put together this podcast and we
have the last few years.
That's why I like doing it.
That's why I call it up.
I'm like,
I want to do your podcast so we can hang out and talk.
We're,
we're,
we're very lucky in life.
But you do get busy.
This is so,
this is actually,
these are great conversations that we have.
They're fucking awesome that you never really do when you're just hanging around
because a lot of it's grab ass.
You just getting distracted by a bunch of other people.
But it's focused for forced to sit down and focus and talk about what's
important to you.
You figure things out as you're talking.
You could,
you imagine all the people that are,
if you imagine if you're standing in front of 400,000 people,
you would never be,
feel so free to talk and be boring.
God,
you'd be terrified.
I'd be by be releasing Doug.
I do whatever I could and,
and 4,000 people we did 50 with,
uh,
with Jimmy Norton.
We did a crowd of 50,
and it was definitely a different experience.
We're going to do more of those.
Um,
uh,
we got three this week.
We got a red as easy tomorrow.
And then we got Doug Benson on Wednesday.
All right,
bitches.
Thank you to the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link and enter in the code name
Rogan,
you'll get 15% off the number one sex toy for men.
You want one?
Did I ever give you one?
I'll give you one.
Did you use it?
Did you fuck holes in it already?
Subscribed to a death squad on iTunes.
It's Brian Reichel,
Aka Aka red band.
He's got a whole network of funny comedians that we were all friends with and
they have a,
a bunch of different shows.
Your mom's house with Thompson Gora is particularly excellent as is the the
skeptic tank with Ari Shaffir.
That's fucking awesome.
One.
And then the noise show with Sam Tripoli.
We have Lexi belt at night on the nightly show and they're not there.
They're really fun.
And if you're looking for some free entertainment,
it's available on iTunes and on desk squad.tv San Francisco this weekend.
Almost sold out.
Get on at bitches.
Don't sleep.
I got a lot of new shit.
I haven't been in Edmonton.
Comics come to where?
Where's it?
Edmonton and Alberta.
Canada,
which is the shit.
So,
uh,
let me,
Sam,
Tripoli and Thompson Gore at Cobb's,
I believe it's Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday.
I think Saturday is already sold out and most of Friday and Thursday are sold
out to south Wednesday.
How's Wednesday this Wednesday?
Sal's comedy hole in La.
Eight o'clock.
Yeah.
If you go to South County,
the whole.com,
it's very fucking sketchy place.
They don't have real like,
no,
it's great.
It's really deep.
You can't like buy tickets online.
RSVP though.
And there's all up and RSVP.
Yeah,
there's only 80 seats.
It fills up and it's fun.
And I can old school,
New York kind of spot where they did an alternative comedy,
you know what I mean?
It's a good place to fuck around.
I sometimes will go on stage.
It was just an idea there and just ramp,
you know,
it's,
it's a really,
it's only like eight or 90 people.
Shazamm me too.
I'm going to do it first.
Oh No.
My prints.
No.
As soon as we get out of here.
All right,
ladies.
Jet will take you very much.
We'll see tomorrow.
I love you bitches.
[inaudible].